schizophrenic mutant David Haller from
FX's Legion based on the x-men character
of the same name it's played by an
English actor you swear you've seen
before Dan Stevens has popped up to
steal scenes in a wide variety of
well-received unusual and offbeat
projects in the last decade or so making
him one of those actors that's hard to
place why is he so familiar Stephens got
his very first on-screen credit in the
miniseries Frankenstein in 2004 and
continued popping up in TV adaptations
of classic works over the next few years
such as Dracula in 2006 sent some
sensibility in 2008 and the turn of the
screw in 2009 Stephen says he had done
quite a few period dramas at this point
was ready not to do another one
which brings us to another one Stephens
big breakthrough came in 2010 when he
landed his role as the lovable cousin
Matthew Crawley in the beloved BBC
costume drama Downton Abbey yep
Stephens almost didn't take the gig that
shot him up to stardom but he says the
well-crafted relationship between
Matthew and Lady Mary compelled them to
get on board if show me I've been living
in a dream it's time to return to real
life
wish me luck with a very Stevens played
Matthew too much acclaim for three
seasons before departing the show in an
unexpected fashion that disappointed
many Downton fans shortly after his exit
from the Abbey Stevens appeared on the
big screen in 2013's the fifth estate a
fictionalized accounts of the founding
of the ever controversial online outfit
WikiLeaks
playing a small but important role
opposite fellow English heartthrob
Benedict Cumberbatch Stevens played Ian
Katz a real-life editor from The
Guardian anyone can take upon this
information and post it up on the
website including news people buy on
paper something a little more discerning
people still buying your paper next
Stevens appeared in two standout
installments of the character-driven
series high-maintenance playing a
cross-dressing stay-at-home dad stoner
and struggling writer named Colin
talking about
love this oh thank you
Stephens appeared bolt in an episode in
the original web-based run in 2014 and
the second episode of the HBO
incarnation landing the gig after
publicly praising the series as
brilliance in his monthly column for The
Telegraph in 2013 Stevens had a busy
year in 2014 one of his most memorable
film roles came in Adam wingers
fantastic thriller the guest where he
plays an intensely charming but very bad
man employing deadly fighting skills in
a flawless American accent good America
Stephens plays an ex-military houseguest
with an unknown past who charms his way
into a family's good graces looking like
the best thing to ever happen to them
before the darts of serving truth comes
out Stevens also has a role in one of
Adam Sandler's weirdest movies the
cobbler it's about a shoe repairman with
an inexplicably magical stitching
machine who can literally become another
person if he wears their shoes the
poorly received 2014 film does provide
viewers at the distinct pleasure of
watching Stephen play Adam Sandler in
another body an unusually layered acting
challenge it ain't your kid boy mainly
bring in the Kinect we ask you really
can wait oh yeah but when he wasn't
hanging out with Adam Sandler Stephens
found himself acting opposite Liam
Neeson in the meditative 2014 crime
drama a walk among the tombstones
Stephens plays a man named kenny kristo
who enlists Neeson's ex-cop character to
help him solve a mystery it was kid
never away when did this happen
yesterday you should be talking to the
FBI I talk to media
it's another change in look and accent
for Stevens a big departure from his
dressed up Downton days but that was
nothing compared to his final big role
in 2014
night into Museum Seger of the tomb for
the second night at the Museum sequel
Stevens joined an eclectic cast of
historical figures come to life as Sir
Lancelot and his performance steals the
show funerals of President of the United
States of America I have no idea what
that means
Stevens plays the Arthurian legend as an
affable dimwit in search of the Holy
Grail but stops along the way to battle
and tame reanimated dinosaur skeleton
most recently Stevens was instrumental
in bringing Disney's animated classic
feuding the
these two live action playing the Beast
to Emma Watson Belle this 2017
adaptation aside from the opening scenes
prior to his transformation Stephen
spends most of the movie as a
computer-generated creation but the
animators didn't do all the work
Stephens had to essentially perform the
role twice once on the physical set
doing body work while wearing stilts and
once alone surrounded by cameras
capturing every nuance of his face he
really read every one of these books
supporting Greek the result was a
performance hailed by variety as alive
with forlorn longing with Stephens
playing the beast as a kind of royal
version of the Elephant Man proving yet
again that his talents are legion thanks
for watching click the looper icon and
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to